Hi everyone. I hope everybody's doing
well and welcome to another tango
technique class.
In previous classes we have been working
with basic movements like change of
weight, crosses, steps forward, back,
side, pivots in both directions more or
less individually.
In this class and in the classes that
follow, we will combine these basic
movements into short sequences
and then we will change directions, we
will change sides, we will change feet
in order to find as many combinations
and possibilities with these basic
movements. This is my method. This is
how I work when I train tango technique.
I start with a few basic movements, I
put them in a sequence and then I try to
go systematically through every possible
combination I can find with those
movements.
The point of this method is that later
when you go dancing and you do any
arbitrary figure,
um the movements that you need and the
combination of movements that you need
to do that figure correctly already
feels familiar because you have found it
before and you have practiced it before.
Yeah, and that's going to be good for
you.
So what we will do today is we will
start with a warm-up today with a new
exercise for our hips
and then we will use a very simple
structure which is starting from zero
position, step forward, change weight,
step back, change weight. Yeah, very
simple. Forward, change weight, back,
change weight. Of course with both legs.
Forward, change weight, back, change
weight. And then we will combine these
with crosses, different crosses.
Forward, crossing back, in zero
position, different sides and then we
will find lots of combinations with
these movements which will be very
useful, okay?
So I hope you like it and let's go for
the warm-up. Okay, warm-up. So we will
start with a new exercise that hopefully
will improve your posture and this will
be an exercise for your hip
to learn to place the hip correctly. So,
you need a wall for this exercise.
I'll use this one.
Uh, first, open your hands, put them in
front of you like this,
and put them on the wall.
You should have a distance between your
hands more or less a little bit more
than your shoulders. You should also
open your feet
more or less shoulder-wide, yeah? And
then
just step a bit away from the wall so
that you can bend the torso forward like
this.
Put your hands above your head, yeah?
Put your head
between your arms more or less. And then
the exercise is like this. We're going
to tilt the hip outside, backwards,
and then we will tilt it inside,
forward. Okay? Outside, backward, and
inside. We will do this 16 times. Let's
do it together.
One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
and eight more. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
okay?
Now we repeat this exercise but standing
without the wall.
So for this one,
uh place your hands behind your head and
use this movement in order to lift your
rib cage away from your hip, yeah? So
that you free your waist. This area is
free and you can move your hip better,
okay?
And you should also keep your feet a bit
open,
same width as your uh shoulders.
And then we will do the same thing. I
will show you in profile so you can see
it better. We will tilt the hip
backwards, outside, and then inwards
to the front, okay? Let's do this 16
times.
One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
and eight more. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
okay?
Good.
So now we will do the rest of the
exercises which will be the same as what
we have been doing before, but for each
exercise don't forget your hip. Try to
have your hip always placed
inside, yeah? Try to tilt it forward.
And keep this position meanwhile you do
the rest of the exercises. So, we will
continue by putting our legs together,
feet in zero position, and then we will
do shoulder rotations. Yeah? Remember,
relax the shoulders and keep your elbows
straight.
Place your hip, and then we do eight
shoulder rotations. One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight. Now, we will do eight circles
with the arms. Remember to stretch your
elbows and keep the shoulders down and
open the chest when you open the arms,
okay? Remember your hip, yeah? Keep it
always tilted forward. Let's do eight
circles. One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
and eight.
Now, we do four stretches of our side,
yeah? Remember, we lift down our arm
until it looks up, then we slide the
hand that is on the leg down until we
can touch the side of our knee more or
less. We hold the stretch for a few
seconds, and then we use the hand that
is up to pull ourselves up again. And
then we drop the arm and repeat to the
other side, okay? And during the whole
exercise, don't forget to keep your hip
tilted forward, okay? So, let's start.
One,
down,
and up.
And one
down
and up.
Two
down
and up.
Two
down
and up.
Three
down
and up. Don't forget your hip.
Three
down
and up.
And the last one, four
down
and up.
Four
down
and up. Okay? The next exercise is
rotations for the middle, for the torso.
So, we open the legs, we bend the knees
slightly, we make a circle with our arms
in front of us, and we rotate the torso
relaxed left and right. We do it 16
times. During the exercise, keep your
hip
tilted forward. Okay? Let's do it
together. One
two and three
four and
five
six and
seven and eight. Eight more. One
two and
three and
four
five and
six and
seven and
eight. Okay.
For the next one, we stretch the knees,
but we keep the hip tilted forward, and
then we place our hands behind our head
again, and then we bend
forward until our back is parallel with
the floor
and then we continue going forward going
down
and then we bounce three times 1 2 3
and then we go up
so I will show you on profile
keep your legs straight
your hip tilted forward
and then let's do eight together
parallel
1 2 3
and up
parallel
1 2 3
and up
parallel
1 2 3
and up
parallel
1 2 3
and up
parallel
1 2 3
and up
parallel
1 2 3
and up
parallel
1 2 3
and up
and 8
parallel
1 2 3
and up
Okay for the next one
we will keep the legs open we grab our
hip and then we go back with the hip and
then we will do circles with the hip. We
go to the side, feel the stretch on the
inside of the leg that is extending,
then go forward with the hip,
then go to the other side. Now you
should feel the stretch in on the inside
of this leg,
and then go back, yeah, for a full
circle. And during the whole time, try
to keep your hip well placed, tilted
inwards. Don't tilt it back like this,
yeah. Keep it inwards. Okay, so
let's start. Let's do eight circles in
each direction.
And
one
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
and change direction. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
Okay.
And now for the last one, we close our
legs.
And this exercise is to strengthen our
foot joint, yeah, and our lower leg in
general. So, remember, keep your hip
well placed, tilted forward, and then
grab your hips, bend your knees, and
bounce three times in this position,
very relaxed, then stretch your knees,
and then go up on the toes. Yeah?
Remember, don't let your feet open like
this. This is very bad. Keep your feet
straight and together. Okay? And when
you are going up, remember to keep your
hip tilted forward. Yeah?
And then go down and repeat eight times.
Let's do it together.
So, place your hip
and go down and bounce three times.
One.
And go up.
And down.
Two.
And go up.
And down.
Three.
And go up.
And down.
Four.
And go up.
And down.
Five.
And go up.
And down. Six.
And down. Seven.
And go up.
And down. Eight.
And down.
Okay, that was the warm-up.
Let's start with the first exercise.
Okay, for the first exercise, we will
use a very simple step structure, which
is just going forward, then changing
weight, going back, changing weight,
going forward, changing weight, going
back, changing weight. Of course, we
will do it with both legs. So, in this
movement, you are always going to have a
leading leg, the leg that goes forward,
and then a following leg, the leg that
follows going forward or going back. If
I show you from behind,
if you go forward with the right leg,
the right leg is your leading leg
because it's the first leg that goes
forward and then the left leg is the
following leg because it follows the
right leg going forward. Then you change
weight and then the right leg is the
leading leg
because it's going back first and then
the left leg is the following leg
because it's following the movement
backwards and then you change weight.
Okay? Of course,
we will reverse it also. We will use the
left leg also as the leading leg going
forward, changing weight with right and
then
left leg going back, change weight with
right. Yeah? So, in this case, the left
leg is the leading leg and the right leg
is the following leg. Okay? Good. Now,
I'm going to show you from the side
because
we need to remember a few technical
considerations to do this movement
correctly.
First of all, starting zero position and
then place your hip correctly, tilt it
inwards. Then bend your knees. Okay?
Flex your knees like this, relax them.
Then remember the phases of uh
the step, yeah? That you start by
opening the free leg, then push and
slide, push with the standing leg and
slide with the free leg, then change
weight, transfer the weight and then
close your free leg. So, open, push and
slide, change weight, close. Open, push
and slide, change weight, close. Okay?
The next thing I want you to try
is that after you move forward,
when you are going to close the back
leg, try to point the toes down. Try to
keep the leg open as long as you can and
then keep the toes pointed down. And
then change weight. When you are going
back with the leading leg, yeah, then
also try to point the toes back down,
yeah, like this. Don't go back like
this.
It's not wrong, but right now let's try
to work more with our feet, yeah, with
our foot joint. So, when you're going
back, point the toes down and then
change the weight, yeah? So, again,
knees flexed,
then go forward, point the toes down on
the back foot, change weight, and then
point the toes down on the leg that is
going back.
Back, okay?
The next thing I want you to try,
if you want to make the exercise more
complete,
is to use dissociation. I will show you
from the front first. So, when you are
going forward, yeah, the torso turns
slightly towards the leg that is going
forward, yeah? So, this leg or this leg,
yeah? Always towards the leg that is
going forward. When you change weight
and you go back, the torso turns towards
the leg that stays forward, okay?
This is dissociation.
Forward
and back, yeah? So, if I show you from
behind,
if your active leg is the right leg,
that means the right leg is now going
forward, the torso goes to the right,
yeah? Be careful, don't make this
movement with the shoulders.
Don't move Don't do it like this. This
torsion has to come from as low as
possible, just above your waist, yeah?
You remember the exercise we do in the
warm-up, this one?
Well, that's why we do it because then
we can use
this dissociation, yeah, from the waist.
And then change weight, your torso is
neutral, and then you go back with the
right leg, and the
opposition, the dissociation is to the
left because that's the leg that stays
forward, yeah? So,
right
and left. Of course, if your active leg
is the left one, you go left
forward, then your dissociation is
to the left because that's the leg
that's forward.
And then you change weight,
and then when you go back with left,
your torso goes to the right because
that's the leg that stays forward.
Okay?
So, try to
incorporate all these elements when you
do the exercise. So,
we are going to do it
first
using the right leg to go forward, and
then the left leg. But if you are
mirroring the image, you can use the
other leg. It doesn't matter because we
will use both, okay?
And we're going to use the metronome for
the exercise. Now, for the ones who
missed the explanation of the first
class,
the reason why I use the metronome is
very simple. There are two reasons.
First, it's because I cannot have tango
music in the videos, otherwise I will
get copyright strikes, and the videos
might be taken down. It has happened to
me in the past. And I don't want to use
non-tango music for the tango exercises
because I find that it doesn't fit. The
second, and for me personally more
important, is that the metronome is the
best method, hands down, to improve the
precision of your timing. Ask any
musician, any drummer, any performer who
needs to
improve the precision of and be very
precise with timing, they work with
metronomes for hours. And there is no
reason why us dancers cannot have the
same discipline
and
use the metronome to improve the timing
of our legs.
So, as always, I set my metronome to 58
bpm and two beats per bar.
And yeah, try to be precise.
Try to step exactly when you hear the
beat of the metronome. So, let's I'm
going to do it 16 times on one side
starting with the right leg.
So, remember place your hip, bend your
knees,
put your weight on the left leg, and go
forward with the right.
And
one
and
two.
And
three.
four.
And
five.
six.
And
seven.
eight.
And eight more.
One.
Two.
And
three.
four.
And
five.
six.
And
seven.
eight.
Okay, now let's do the other side.
Zero position, bend your knees, place
your hip, put your weight on the right
and start with left.
And
one
two
and
three
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight.
And eight more. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight.
Okay, good.
Easy enough, but not so easy if you
really pay attention to every little
technical detail. The toes, the
dissociation, okay? So this was the
basic structure. Now we are going to put
all kinds of crosses inside here.
Let's do it in the next block. Okay, for
this exercise
every time we go forward with one leg,
whichever it is, we will cross back with
the other. Okay? Cross back. This is the
first cross we're going to use. And then
we will uncross the other foot and then
go back and change weight. Yeah? So,
it's front, cross back,
back, change weight.
Front, cross back, back, change weight.
Okay?
Now,
uh apart from all the technical aspects
we discussed in the previous block,
the specific technical ideas for this
one is that
you have to try to make as compact a
cross as you can. Don't leave space
between your feet. I'll show you profile
because this way you can see it better.
Yeah? Try to make a compact cross. Yeah?
So, that the legs touch. For this, it
helps to bend the leg that is front,
bend the knee,
so that then you make space for the leg
that is behind. Okay?
Um if I show you from the front,
when you go front, now you have to put
the back knee behind the front knee.
Don't have both knees visible from the
front. This is wrong because then your
feet are on a weird angle on the floor
and it and it's really hard to get out
of here. So, the correct way is to place
your back knee behind the front knee, so
that your legs make an X. Yeah? And the
center of the X
are the knees. So, you only see one knee
from the front. If I show you from
behind,
you go front with right, for example,
the right is your leading leg. So, then
you cross back
and you put
the knee behind the other knee and you
bend the knees. And then you uncross the
foot. For For uncrossing the foot, I
show you from the front.
Remember, don't lift the foot. Yeah?
Don't do this. Keep the foot on the
floor and try to make a very small
circle around your standing foot. Okay?
From the profile, yeah? You just cross.
So, now keep the foot on the floor and
then make a small circle around your
standing foot and then go back. If
you're a lady and you're wearing high
heels, be careful when you are in cross
that you don't scratch the skin of your
standing foot with the heel. Yeah? So,
maybe for you you have to lift a little
bit the heel or you have to make a
bigger movement.
But, try not to hurt yourself with your
heel. Okay?
So,
uh we will do it 16 times one side and
the other side. Okay?
Uh and we will do it with a metronome
again.
58 bpm
and two right two beats per bar.
Okay. So, get ready. Zero position.
Place your hip.
Bend your knees.
Put your weight on the left foot and we
start with right forward.
And one,
close.
Two,
Three,
close.
Four, close.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
And
eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
three
four
five
six
seven
and
eight
Okay? Now let's do the other side.
Zero position.
Place your hip, bend the knees, flex
them, relax the legs.
Put your weight on the right and we
start with left forward.
And
one
two, cross behind
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Eight more. One
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
Okay? Very good.
Let's go to the next exercise. Okay, for
the next exercise we will do the
opposite. Every time we go back, we will
use a cross front. So, we will do front,
change weight without cross, and then
back, cross front. And cross, front,
change weight, back, cross front.
Front, change weight, back, cross front.
Okay? So, remember the technical tips.
Hip place, knees bend, open, push and
slide, change weight, close, and then
point the toes
when you are going forward, point the
toe on the back foot, then change
weight, and when you go back, point the
toe with the leading foot.
Okay? And if you can, use dissociation.
Turn the torso always in the direction
of the leg that is
front. Okay? And remember the knees.
When you cross, you should have only one
knee visible from the front. Yeah? Not
like this. Okay? So, let's do this with
the metronome again.
16 times
each side.
So, zero position, bend the knees, flex
the hip,
put the weight on the left, and we start
with right front.
And
one.
Cross. Two.
Cross. Three.
Cross. Four.
Cross. Five.
Six.
Seven.
And
eight.
one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay? Now, let's do it to the other
side.
Zero position, place the hip, bend the
knees.
Put your weight on the right and start
with the left forward.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Goes forward. Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Okay? Good.
Let's go to the next one.
For the next exercise, we're going to
use a cross forward when we go forward.
So, it's going to look like this. You go
forward and then you cross forward and
then you go back and you change weight.
Okay? Forward, cross forward,
back, change weight. Forward, cross
forward, back, change weight. Yeah? And
remember, if I show you from the front,
forward, make a small circle
around your standing foot and make a
compact cross. All the crosses in this
exercises look the same. Look always
like this. Zero position, legs making an
X with the center of the X on your
knees. Okay?
So, let's do this one.
Metronome again.
And let's do it 16 times on each side.
Okay?
Zero position.
Place your hip, bend the knees,
embrace, put your weight on the left
leg, and we start with right forward.
And
forward, cross.
two,
cross.
And
three,
cross.
And
four, cross.
And five, cross.
And
six.
seven.
And
eight.
Eight more.
One.
And
two.
three.
And
four.
five.
And
six.
seven.
And
eight.
Okay? Good.
Now, this is the better side.
Zero position, place your hip, bend the
knees, put your weight on the right, and
we start with the left front, and then
we cross forward 16 times.
And
one.
two.
And
three.
four.
And
five.
six.
And
seven.
eight.
Eight more.
One.
And
two.
three.
And
four.
five.
And
six.
seven.
And
eight.
okay? Good.
Let's go to the next one. Okay, for the
next one, we're going to use a cross
back every time we go back. So, it's
going to be front, change weight, back,
cross back. Yeah? Front, change weight,
back, cross back. So, here is very
important again to keep your knees
flexed and then make a small circle
around your
standing foot with the free foot when
you cross back. And bend the standing
leg so that you have more space for the
back leg to make a compact
cross. Yeah? I'll show you from behind.
You go front, change weight,
back, and then cross. Yeah?
And then push with your
following leg so that the leading leg
can go forward again. Okay? So, let's do
it 16 times
to each side.
Okay.
So, zero position, place your hip, bend
the knees,
pull your weight from the left leg, and
then we start front with right.
And
one
cross, two
cross, three
cross, four
cross, five
cross, six
cross, seven
cross, eight
And eight more. One
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
Okay? Now, let's do the left side. Zero
position. Raise your hip.
And then put your weight on your
right leg and we start with left to the
front.
And
one
Close back. two
Close back.
three
four
Close back.
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
Eight more. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
Okay?
Very good.
So, with this one we finished all the
possibilities that we have going back
and forth with only one cross. Now, in
the next block we're going to see more
possibilities using two crosses, when it
gets really interesting. Okay, so for
the first exercise with two crosses,
we will do the following. Every time you
go forward, you cross back. And every
time you go back, you cross forward. So,
the structure is step forward, cross
back. Step back, cross forward. Step
forward, cross back. Step back, cross
forward. Okay? So, now let's remember
all the technical aspects that we need
to think about and take care of when we
do these movements. So, start with knees
relaxed. Yeah? Relax your knees. Then,
remember the stages of the step. So, we
open the free leg, we push with the
standing leg and slide with the free
leg, we transfer the weight, and then we
close the free leg. Okay?
Then, don't forget to point the toes.
When you're going forward, point the
toes of the foot that stays back towards
the floor. And then, point the toes of
the foot that is going back to the
floor.
Yeah?
So, you go forward, point the toes. You
go back, point the toes. Yeah? The next
thing is make the cross compact. Yeah?
Don't leave the cross half closed. Yeah?
Close it completely. And remember, if I
show you from the front, remember to
place one knee behind the other knee
when you cross. Yeah? Don't have both
knees showing forward. One knee behind.
Your legs should look like an X, and the
center of the X is on your knees. Yeah?
So,
one knee in front of the other. And
for uh don't forget also the
dissociation. Yeah? If I show you from
behind,
when you go forward, you turn the torso
towards the leg, the is going forward.
In this case, the leading leg is the
right leg. Yeah? And when you are going
backwards, the torso turns slightly
towards the leg that stays forward.
Yeah?
If I show you from the front,
my torso turns to the leading leg when I
go forward,
and then
to the following leg when I go back,
because that's the leg that is forward.
Okay? Always to the leg that is forward.
And there is one last trick that you
need to know for this exercise.
If you do your steps forward and back in
two parallel lines, like you always do
when you dance with a partner,
uh every time you cross,
the crosses will take you slowly towards
the side,
and you will end up here. Yeah?
So, in order to avoid this, I recommend
that your leading leg always crosses the
step a little bit in front of the
following leg. Not too much, because
then you would end up with the opposite
problem going to the other side, but
just a little bit. Just put one foot in
front of the other. That's enough. So
that the following leg can move in a
straight line. Yeah? Now, the leading
leg is going to cross a little bit
behind the following leg, so that the
following leg
moves in a straight line. If I show you
from behind, yeah? My leading leg, in
this case uh case the right one, goes
forward a bit crossed, so that the
following leg can move in a straight
line.
And then,
the same when I go back. The leading leg
crosses a little bit, so that the
following leg can move in a straight
line.
Okay?
Good. So, let's uh do this one
16 times
with a metronome
to both sides.
Okay, so get ready. Zero position.
Relax the knees. Place your hip,
tummy embrace, put your weight on the
left leg so that you can go forward with
the right.
Okay?
And
one, cross back.
And cross forward.
Two, cross back.
Cross forward.
Three, cross back.
Four, cross back.
Cross forward. Five.
And six.
Seven.
Eight.
And eight more. One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
And eight.
And okay, very good. Let's do the other
side.
So get ready. Zero position.
Relax your knees. Place your hip, tummy
embrace, and put your weight on the
right leg so that you can start forward
with the left.
And
one.
two.
And
three.
four.
And
five.
Uh,
six.
seven.
Uh,
eight.
Uh, eight more. One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Uh,
eight.
okay?
Very good.
So, let's go to the next exercise. Okay,
for the next exercise using two crosses,
it's going to be like this.
Every time you go forward, you will
cross forward. And when you go back, you
will also cross forward. So, two crosses
forward, yeah?
Step forward, cross forward. Step back,
cross forward. Step forward, cross
forward. Step back, cross forward. Okay?
Now, don't forget the technical uh,
things we have been discussing. So,
relax your knees, bend your knees. Don't
forget to point the toes down to the
floor on the foot that stays back. Then,
make a small circle with your foot
around the standing foot, yeah? A small
circle around your standing foot.
Then, change weight. Then, don't forget
to point the toes also on the foot that
is going back.
Yeah, and then make a compact cross,
yeah, without space
between your feet
and with knees one behind the other.
Okay? And also, don't forget, if you
can, the dissociation, yeah, in which
your torso always turns a tiny bit
towards the leg that is forward, either
when you're going forward towards the
leg that's going forward, or when you're
going back towards the leg that is stays
forward. Okay? The following leg. Okay?
So, um
good, let's do it 16 times
with a metronome.
Okay.
Zero position, relax your knees, place
your hip,
and embrace, put your weight on the
left,
and we will go forward with right.
One goes forward, back goes forward.
Two goes forward, back goes forward.
Three goes forward, back goes forward.
Four goes forward, back goes forward.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Five.
Eight.
Eight more.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
and
8.
Okay, very good.
Now, let's go to the other side.
So,
get ready in your position, relax your
knees, place your hip
down and brace, put your weight on the
right leg, and we start with left front.
Okay?
And
2 Let's go forward, back, let's go
forward.
and 6
And eight more. 1
and 8
Okay?
Very good.
Let's go to the next combination. For
the next exercise with two crosses,
it will be like this.
When you go forward, you are going to
cross back again, and when you go back,
you are also going to cross back, okay?
So, it's like this. Step forward, cross
back, step back, cross back, step
forward, cross back, step back,
cross back, okay? So, two crosses back
this time, yeah? So, don't forget,
especially when you're going back, to
make a small circle around your standing
foot, a small circle on the floor, yeah?
If I show you from behind,
you start in zero position, you walk
forward, you cross back, put your knees
one behind the other, and then
you go back, and here you make a small
circle
around your standing foot,
and then you cross back,
okay?
Good.
So, let's make 16
each side.
So, get ready, zero position,
flex your knees,
place the hip,
down and brace,
put your weight on the left, and we
start forward with the right.
And
one, cross back,
back, cross back.
Two, cross back,
and
cross back.
Three, cross back, and
Four, cross back,
and
cross back.
Five, cross back,
and
cross back.
Six, cross back,
and don't forget dissociation, seven.
And
eight.
And eight more. One,
and
two,
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
okay?
Now let's do the other side.
Zero position, relax knees.
Place the hip and don't forget the hip
during the exercise, yeah? That's
important. Keep it
tilted in inside.
And then turn on brace, put your weight
on the right and we start with left
forward.
And
one
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
and eight more. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight.
And
okay, great. Very good.
So, the good news is that there is only
one exercise left. So, let's go to do
it. Okay, for the last exercise with two
crosses, we will do this.
When you go forward,
you will cross forward. And when you go
back, you will cross back. So, one cross
forward, one cross back. Step forward,
cross forward. Step back, cross back.
Step forward, cross forward. Step back,
cross back. So, in this particular
combination, your following leg, the leg
behind,
has the most amount of work because
every time that the leading leg goes
forward or back, yeah, the following leg
has to go around it, yeah, further in
order to reach the cross. Yeah, so when
you go back,
yeah, the leading leg goes back, the
following leg has to go around further,
yeah, in order to reach the cross. So,
here, your following leg is working a
lot, doing all these little circles,
yeah.
It's a very interesting one, okay? So,
let's do 16 to each side.
So, get ready.
Zero position. Relax your knees. Raise
the hip. Down with your brace. And put
your weight on the left, so you go
forward with your right.
And
one, cross forward, back, cross back.
Two, cross forward, back, cross back.
Three, cross forward, back, cross back.
Four, cross forward, back, cross back.
Five.
And
six.
and
seven
eight
and eight more. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
okay, very good. Let's do the other
side. Zero position.
Relax the knees, place the hip
down and brace, put your weight on the
right
so that you will forward with the left.
And
one
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
seven
and
eight
and eight more. One
and
two
three
and
four
five
and
six
And
seven.
And eight.
And okay?
Great.
Very good.
So, the point is that if you go through
all of the sequence of exercises that we
did today,
later when you go dancing, yeah,
hopefully very soon,
um you won't have any problem at all
with any combination of uh steps forward
or back with crosses forward or back in
any figure that you might do. Because
you will have practiced and you will
have gone through every possible
combination of what you could do with
these movements, okay? And that's the
point. That's the advantage.
So, um
thank you for doing this whole thing
with me.
And also, I want to recommend you, well,
as always, go again through the video,
repeat the exercises until they feel
uh more or less comfortable, until you
can do them remembering every technical
aspect that we did today, dissociation,
toes, compact crosses, knees,
uh stable steps, yeah, good timing.
Also, do it with music if you want. And
also, I want to tell you these classes
are not supposed to be like you do it
once and then uh you forget about it. Um
I recommend you to go back to the
previous classes. For example, start
with the first one. And then do those
exercises again, because that's what I
do. These exercises that I'm showing
you, I do them regularly. For example,
the balance exercises of class number
one, which you can find easily at the
top of the playlist, I do them every a
yeah? Because if you do these exercises
of each class just once, then you have
no way to see if you are making any
progress. So, I recommend you to go back
to previous classes or find one that you
like, and then do those exercises again
and see if you feel that the exercises
are easier to do.
Because that means that you are
improving, that you are dancing better,
okay? So, that was my last tip. Thank
you very much, and I will see you very
soon in the next class. Bye-bye.